Hi, Josh and Craig.
嗨，乔什和克雷格。
My name is Michaela and I have been watching him for nine years because of my beautiful girlfriend, Karmina.
我叫 Michaela，因为我漂亮的女朋友 Karmina，我已经关注他九年了。
Before meeting her, I hadn't seen the show at all.
在认识她之前，我根本没有看过这部剧。
I had no idea what it was about and honestly at first, I thought it was a little bit difficult to watch, mainly with the Barney character being so horrifying to women.
我不知道它是关于什么的，老实说，一开始我觉得这有点难看，主要是巴尼这个角色对女性来说太可怕了。
But over the years I've grown to love Eva Barney and the show and it's a regular everyday part of our lives and we watch it quite literally every single day.
但多年来，我越来越喜欢伊娃·巴尼和这部剧，它已经成为我们日常生活的一部分，我们几乎每天都会看它。
I really resonate with Ted because he blurted out, I love you so quickly and I think I blur it out.
我真的和泰德产生了共鸣，因为他脱口而出，我这么快就爱你了，我想我把它说得含糊不清了。
I love you to her on our third or fifth date or something.
在我们第三次或第五次约会之类的时候，我对她爱你。
I also wanted to give a little shout out to Josh's wife, being a therapist.
我还想对乔什的妻子表示一点赞扬，她是一名治疗师。
She's so cool.
她太酷了。
I love hearing her takes on how I met your mother because they are just so, so interesting.
我喜欢听她讲述我是如何认识你母亲的，因为它们非常非常有趣。
And I'm also a therapist, so it's nice to hear that perspective too.
我也是一名治疗师，所以很高兴听到这个观点。
Yeah.
是的。
And I wanted to say to Carmina, you're good looking, you're funny, you're smart.
我想对卡米娜说，你很漂亮，你很有趣，你很聪明。
Now would you frickin marry me already?
现在你他妈愿意嫁给我了吗？
I'm a low EI won't be soon In New York City When I see you Please permit me To tell you everything In New York City Well hello and welcome to another episode of How We Made Your Mother I'm Josh Radner I'm joined by my friend Craig Thomas Hey Craig Hey Josh We are making our way through How I Met Your Mother A series that we collaborated on for many years.
我的情商很低，不会很快在纽约见到你时请允许我告诉你在纽约的一切好吧，你好，欢迎收看《我们如何造就你的母亲》的另一集我是乔什·拉德纳，我的朋友克雷格·托马斯也加入了嘿克雷格·嘿乔希我们正在穿越《老爸老妈的浪漫史》我们合作多年的系列剧。
Years ago, I played Ted Mosby on that show.
几年前，我在那部剧中扮演泰德·莫斯比。
Craig co-created the show with Carter Bayes.
克雷格与卡特·贝叶斯共同创作了该剧。
But we're also making history on the pod today because I believe that was our first marriage proposal on the podcast, right?
但我们今天也在播客上创造了历史，因为我相信这是我们在播客上的第一次求婚，对吧？
That was a marriage proposal on the podcast.
那是播客上的求婚。
And that's what just happened.
这就是刚刚发生的事情。
That's just how we're waiting.
我们就是这样等待的。
How are we going to know?
我们怎么知道？
I know.
我知道。
How will we know?
我们怎么知道？
And also, like, when does this air versus when do we go?
还有，比如，这个节目什么时候播出，我们什么时候去？
Like, we're way ahead of the story.
就像，我们远远领先于故事。
Like we know this is a strange thing.
就像我们知道这是一件奇怪的事情。
We know way more longer than Karmina will know this.
我们知道的时间比卡米娜知道的时间要长得多。
Karmina, we're gonna be sitting on this for like a month and a half.
Karmina，我们要在这件事上待一个半月左右。
I don't know how we're gonna keep it to ourselves.
我不知道我们要如何保守秘密。
But we hope that was a great way to receive a marriage proposal, we're thrilled.
但我们希望这是接受求婚的好方法，我们很兴奋。
Thank you.
谢谢。
When you please tell us what happens, you gotta follow us.
当你告诉我们发生了什么时，你必须关注我们。
We need a follow up.
我们需要跟进。
We need visuals and videos.
我们需要视觉效果和视频。
We need, we will accept our wedding invitations, whatever you wanna put them in the mail.
我们需要，我们会接受我们的婚礼请柬，无论您想通过邮件寄什么。
Yeah, and a video of her hearing that would be terrific.
是的，如果有她听证会的视频那就太棒了。
Anyway, well, we often have very special episodes of How We Made Your Mother, but today, very, very special episode of How We Made Your Mother.
不管怎样，我们经常有非常特别的剧集《我们如何创造了你的母亲》，但今天，非常非常特别的一集《我们如何创造了你的母亲》。
Oh, yes.
哦是的。
Oh, yes, very special guest.
哦，是的，非常特别的客人。
I don't know how you're gonna top this special guest.
我不知道你会如何超越这位特别的客人。
It started with a proposal.
它始于一个提案。
It's all downhill from here, but we have one of the greats.
从这里开始一切都在走下坡路，但我们有一位伟大的球员。
And I'll introduce this gentleman because he was one of the earliest believers in How I Met Your Mother.
我要介绍这位先生，因为他是《老爸老妈的浪漫史》最早的信徒之一。
He was on the pilot with Carter and I.
他与卡特和我一起参与试播。
He's a wonderful writer, a wonderful director.
他是一位出色的作家，一位出色的导演。
he directed the episode we're gonna be talking about today too.
他也导演了我们今天要讨论的这一集。
Ladies and gentlemen, one of my best friends, Rob Greenberg.
女士们先生们，我最好的朋友之一，罗布·格林伯格。
Rob.
抢。
Josh, I cray, I see you.
乔什，我哭了，我看到你了。
Thanks for having me, I'm delighted to be here.
谢谢你邀请我，我很高兴来到这里。
Yeah.
是的。
Sorry, all the thunder was stolen by the one in the marriage proposal.
抱歉，所有的风头都被求婚的那个抢走了。
But she did say marry me already.
但她确实已经说过嫁给我了。
So I don't know if it's the first time to talk.
所以不知道是不是第一次说话。
You're gonna parse this now, you're gonna ruin this moment?
你现在要解析这个，你要毁掉这一刻吗？
That's why you brought me down.
这就是你让我失望的原因。
The third time's a charm, yeah.
第三次是一个魅力，是的。
Rob, now when I met Carter, Craig, and Pam in that room, on that rainy day, 20 some years ago, I also met you that day.
罗布，二十年前的那个雨天，当我在那个房间里遇见卡特、克雷格和帕姆时，那天我也遇见了你。
You were in that room at those original auditions and as we have established with the lore that I was the very first person you guys saw on the very first date.
最初的试镜时你就在那个房间里，正如我们所知道的那样，我是你们第一次约会时看到的第一个人。
Do you have a lot of strong memories of that?
你对此有很多深刻的回忆吗？
I do, I do.
我愿意，我愿意。
I said, look, I'm not a fan.
我说，听着，我不是粉丝。
I was very vocal.
我的声音很大。
You were kind for him.
你对他很好。
I was all in like everybody else.
我和其他人一样全力以赴。
Yes, I was there, I was there that day.
是的，我在那儿，那天我在那儿。
But were you, I mean, Craig, this might be a question for you too, but were you like assigned as the adult for these young preschoolers who had their first TV show on here?
但是，我的意思是，克雷格，这对你来说也可能是一个问题，但你是否像这些年轻的学龄前儿童在这里第一次电视节目一样被分配为成年人？
Oh, yes.
哦是的。
They needed an adult.
他们需要一个成年人。
Yeah.
是的。
And somehow I was on the list and we met and hit it off and yes.
不知怎的，我在名单上，我们见面了，一拍即合，是的。
Yeah.
是的。
And can you give us a little bit of your background in television?
您能给我们介绍一下您的电视背景吗？
I know you came from, you were on Frasier for many years.
我知道你来自，你在弗雷泽待了很多年。
Is that right?
是这样吗？
I was on Frasier for many years.
我在弗雷泽待了很多年。
I did a bunch of pilots and I, I don't know, I guess I was directing and writing and various shows.
我做了很多试播集，我不知道，我想我是在导演、编剧和各种节目。
Yes.
是的。
Yeah.
I think I was on, I was on an overall deal at Warner Brothers.
我想我参与了华纳兄弟的整体交易。
Yeah, you were not under a deal.
是的，你们没有达成协议。
You were not under a deal at 20.
你20岁的时候就没有签约。
We met a coral tree on San Vicente.
我们在圣维森特遇到了一棵珊瑚树。
We did.
我们做到了。
That was our meet cute.
那是我们可爱的相遇。
We had our meet to you at a cute little cafe on San Vicente in front wood, which you are a specialist in making sure people come very close to where you live.
我们在圣维森特前树林的一家可爱的小咖啡馆里与您见面，您是确保人们离您住的地方非常近的专家。
do not like.
不喜欢。
I just had done it with Rob a few weeks ago in LA and it was two minutes from his house.
几周前我刚刚在洛杉矶和罗布一起完成了这件事，距离他家只有两分钟的路程。
And Rob, you, I mean, you had us beat by having ever worked on a multi-camera sitcom, which Carter and I had not.
罗布，你，我的意思是，你曾经制作过多镜头情景喜剧，从而击败了我们，而卡特和我却没有。
And I think basically the studio looked at these two 30 year old guys who we looked five.
我认为工作室基本上关注的是这两个 30 岁的家伙，而我们看起来只有五岁。
You were 29.
那年你29岁。
You looked so young, I know.
我知道你看起来很年轻。
And we, and They said, we need an adult and Frasier was a huge hit, and everyone loves you anyway.
我们，他们说，我们需要一个成年人，《弗雷泽》非常受欢迎，无论如何，每个人都爱你。
And they said, Rob, and we met a few different people, if I'm being honest, but we didn't, we loved you, we fell in love.
他们说，罗布，说实话，我们遇到了几个不同的人，但我们没有，我们爱你，我们坠入爱河。
It was a click, and just the same way that it was with Pam.
这是一声点击，就像帕姆那样。
It was just like, again, we just found all the right, perfect people very early on.
就像我们很早就找到了所有合适的、完美的人一样。
It was really- Did you meet with more people after you met with me, or before you met with me?
真是——你是在认识我之后，还是在认识我之前，认识了更多的人？
We got a lot of nose and then we doubled back to you.
我们有很多鼻子，然后我们折返回给你。
Okay, all right, all right.
好吧，好吧，好吧。
Rob, can you, if you can cast your memory back that far, Like, do you remember reading the pilot and what your first impressions were and also what you thought when you met Craig and Carter?
罗布，如果你能把你的记忆回溯到那么远，你是否记得读过试播集，你的第一印象是什么，以及当你遇到克雷格和卡特时的想法？
I, you know, the truth is I don't think a lot about it.
我，你知道，事实是我并没有想太多。
I kind of shoot from my gut.
我有点发自内心地射击。
I read the script and I liked it and I met Carter and Craig and I liked them and I was in.
我读了剧本，我喜欢它，我遇到了卡特和克雷格，我喜欢他们，我就加入了。
Yeah.
是的。
That was it.
就是这样。
I didn't read it five times.
我没读过五遍。
They analyzed it.
他们对此进行了分析。
I didn't do any of that.
我什么也没做。
It's very strange behavior from a Jewish man to not overthink things, but this is why we love you.
对于一个犹太人来说，不去想太多事情是非常奇怪的，但这就是我们爱你的原因。
Exactly.
确切地。
it felt very easy that way.
这样感觉很容易。
And I said, no to a lot of things.
我对很多事情说不。
So it was this one I liked.
所以我喜欢的就是这个。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, you were a good believer in what was special about it.
嗯，你非常相信它的特别之处。
And you always said, don't let them, don't let notes make you whittle down, sand away the edges of what makes a special.
你总是说，不要让它们，不要让笔记让你削弱，打磨掉那些使特别的东西的边缘。
You said, go down, swing in, keep this special, keep this interesting, keep the storytelling unique and singular.
你说，下去，摇摆起来，保持这个特别，保持这个有趣，保持讲故事的独特性和独特性。
And you really helped us in that way, Rob, because we were so new, We had never gone through the pilot process.
罗布，你确实以这种方式帮助了我们，因为我们太新了，我们从未经历过试点过程。
Well, I've been through many pilot process on my own and my friends, and you can see it get derailed during the process, and my job was not to let you get it derailed.
嗯，我自己和我的朋友经历了很多试点过程，你可以看到它在这个过程中脱轨，而我的工作就是不让你让它脱轨。
But isn't it funny that the studio ostensibly assigned you to kind of keep them, you know, playing by the company rules, but you were actually like, don't listen to these people.
但这不是很有趣吗，工作室表面上指派你让他们遵守公司规则，但你实际上是这样的，不要听这些人的。
Yeah, I mean, nothing if not subversive.
是的，我的意思是，如果不是颠覆性的，就没有什么。
Yeah, you really were.
是的，你确实是。
Sure.
当然。
And you were on with us many, many years in the writer's room mostly, but in season two, you started also directing.
你和我们一起度过了很多很多年，大部分时间都在编剧室里，但在第二季中，你也开始担任导演。
You were in the room on and off for all of those years.
这些年来你断断续续地呆在房间里。
And how many years were you on the show, total?
你总共参加这个节目多少年了？
I was on, I was consulting for six years.
我从事咨询工作六年了。
Six years.
六年了。
And then you would still direct now and again, even after you left consulting.
即使在你离开咨询公司之后，你仍然会时不时地担任导演。
Yes.
是的。
You're the only other director of how much a mother that really directed a solid handful or two of episodes besides Pam Fryman.
除了帕姆·弗莱曼（Pam Fryman）之外，你是唯一一位真正导演过一两集的母亲导演。
Do you want to talk about, like, in season two, you started to direct episodes.
你想谈谈，比如，在第二季中，你开始导演剧集吗？
I think Monday Night Football was maybe your second or third, the first one that you tagged in literally because Pam got sick one week.
我想《周一橄榄球之夜》可能是你的第二个或第三个，第一个你因为帕姆生病了一周而标记的。
And the entire nine years that never happened, but our in-house director got sick and like just had to go home on like a Tuesday, right?
整整九年，这种事从未发生过，但我们的内部主管生病了，就像星期二一样必须回家，对吧？
And the day before we were starting to shoot and you literally like stepped in for you went down from the writer's room, Tagged and took the baton and just started directing the episode.
在我们开始拍摄的前一天，你真的喜欢介入，因为你从编剧的房间走下来，贴上标签，接过接力棒，开始导演这一集。
That was your auspicious first one.
那是你的第一个吉祥的事。
I forget what episode that was.
我忘记那是哪一集了。
Until I know what little the director does.
直到我知道导演做了什么。
It's a little, well, well, well, well, well, well machine.
这是一个小，好，好，好，好，好，好机器。
Everyone knows what they're doing.
每个人都知道他们在做什么。
Just get out of the way and make sure it doesn't go off the rail.
只要让开并确保它不会偏离轨道即可。
Which one was that, Rob?
那是哪一个，罗布？
Was that like the second episode of season two?
这就像第二季的第二集吗？
Like, scorpion on the toad?
比如，蝎子骑在蟾蜍身上？
Maybe?
或许？
Was it the end of the toad?
这是蟾蜍的末日吗？
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
I did scorpion on the toad.
我给蟾蜍做了蝎子。
I did columns, and then I did this one on the first episode.
我做了专栏，然后我在第一集中做了这个。
So you did two in a row.
所以你连续做了两次。
So columns in this one were back to back?
那么这一列中的列是背靠背的吗？
They were back to back.
他们背靠背。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, they aired back to back.
好吧，他们连续播出。
Rob, I have a very strong memory of I think it might have been like season five.
罗布，我记得很清楚，我想这可能就像第五季一样。
What was the episode with with Peter Bogdanovich and Michael York where Ted goes to the party?
特德去参加派对的彼得·博格丹诺维奇和迈克尔·约克的那一集是什么？
Yeah.
是的。
That's it.
就是这样。
Peter Bogdanovich obviously this iconic, you know, film director and I'm reciting Dante's Inferno, the opening lines of Dante's Inferno in Italian.
彼得·博格丹诺维奇显然是一位标志性的电影导演，我正在背诵但丁的地狱，意大利语的但丁的地狱的开场白。
And then we started shooting.
然后我们开始拍摄。
But I see Rob go over to Peter Bogdanovich and say can you give him a frame him up?
但我看到罗布走向彼得·博格丹诺维奇说你能帮他陷害他吗？
That was Carter Carter, that wasn't you?
那是卡特卡特，那不是你吗？
Carter was for the means of having to do the movie thing, to the finger frames, it was perfect.
卡特喜欢的是必须做电影的方式，对于手指框架来说，它是完美的。
That was a hundred percent Carter, but the other thing with Bogdanovich was intimidating to direct the legendary director and the very first thing we shot was him and the elevator for the tag, and I forget what he was doing.
那是百分百的卡特，但博格丹诺维奇的另一件事是指导这位传奇导演令人生畏，我们拍摄的第一件事就是他和标签的电梯，我忘记了他在做什么。
He was, you know...
他是，你知道...
He was saying the name, Willam, to fell like a frog.
当他说出“威廉”这个名字时，他就像青蛙一样摔倒了。
Yeah, so he was, of course.
是的，他当然是这样。
Well, that's really what it was.
嗯，事情确实就是这样。
And we set it up and he calls me over.
我们安排好了，他叫我过去。
We set up the camera, we're all ready to go.
我们架好相机，准备出发。
And then he calls me over and goes, won't you want to put the camera closer?
然后他把我叫过去就走了，你不想把相机放近一点吗？
It was like, that's the first thing he said to me.
就像，这是他对我说的第一句话。
And I was like, oh, I don't think I do, but now I do.
我当时想，哦，我不认为我这样做，但现在我知道了。
Yeah, you have to, at that point.
是的，到那时你必须这么做。
I don't think he's used to, like, the Zoom lenses.
我认为他不习惯变焦镜头。
And I wrote you this little day to send you in New York City.
今天我写信给你，是为了送你去纽约。
We'll be right back next to the show.
我们会在演出旁边回来。
So Doug, who's subbing in for our, he's our Alec today.
今天替补我们的道格就是我们的亚历克。
Tell us when this episode aired.
告诉我们这一集什么时候播出。
Alright.
好吧。
to episode 14, Monday Night Football, released February 5th, 2007, this episode was written by Craig Thompson, Carter base.
至 2007 年 2 月 5 日发布的第 14 集“周一橄榄球之夜”，该集由卡特基地的克雷格·汤普森编写。
I wonder if this was aired the Monday right after the Super Bowl had aired, and that's why we planned it that way, I wish that would have been a great thing for me to have researched out of time.
我想知道这是否是在超级碗播出后的周一播出的，这就是我们这样计划的原因，我希望这对我来说是一件伟大的事情，能够及时进行研究。
When was the Super Bowl that year?
那一年的超级碗是什么时候？
Was this literally the Monday after the Super Bowl, and therefore it was like absolutely pretty fun.
这实际上是超级碗之后的星期一，因此这绝对是非常有趣的。
I mean, we've talked about this, how linked we were to the changing of the seasons and the holidays.
我的意思是，我们已经讨论过这个，我们与季节和假期的变化有何联系。
That is just not a thing anymore.
那已经不再是问题了。
I know, it's 10 episodes of something come out, you watch them, whatever the fuck you want.
我知道，有 10 集的东西出来了，你可以看，无论你想看什么。
We were really, it's almost hard to explain that to like, to the youngs today.
我们真的很难向今天的年轻人解释这一点。
We were really tethered to this idea of like hitting holidays, hitting moments, hitting seasons that all had to match.
我们真的很执着于这样的想法：假期、时刻、季节都必须匹配。
The networks really liked that to promote it.
网络真的很喜欢这样来宣传它。
And you were right.
你是对的。
What do you got, Doug?
你有什么，道格？
When did it air?
什么时候播出的？
Sunday, February 4th.
2 月 4 日，星期日。
It was the Monday after the Super Bowl.
那是超级碗比赛结束后的星期一。
So it was well planned.
所以这是精心策划的。
We planned, we were smart.
我们有计划，我们很聪明。
And it was the perfect episode to do today.
这是今天最完美的一集。
Was the Super Bowl on CBS that year?
那年超级碗在 CBS 上播出吗？
I mean, I wonder, it was probably.
我的意思是，我想知道，可能是这样。
I think it was, because I think the show might've got promoted on right there.
我认为是的，因为我认为这部剧可能就在那里进行了宣传。
And that's part of why we had the idea to do this.
这就是我们有这样做的想法的部分原因。
Or maybe we were told you're doing a Super Bowl episode.
或者也许我们被告知您正在制作超级碗剧集。
I think we had been encouraged to do that, and then we're like, how do we, encourage, contractually obligated is another way.
我认为我们被鼓励这样做，然后我们想，我们如何鼓励，合同义务是另一种方式。
And I remember, like, I'm not a football fan, really, if I'm honest, and I remember thinking, how the fuck are we gonna come up with an episode about the Super Bowl?
我记得，就像，我不是一个足球迷，真的，如果我诚实的话，我记得我在想，我们他妈的怎么才能制作一个关于超级碗的剧集？
But in so many ways, we've done this where you think, How do I do a New Year's Eve episode?
但在很多方面，我们已经做到了你想的那样，我该如何制作新年前夜的剧集？
And the answer was in season one, they never get to the New Year's Eve party.
答案是在第一季中，他们从未参加过除夕派对。
You don't even tempts to do New Year's Eve.
你甚至不想过除夕夜。
You do them missing New Year's Eve.
你让他们错过了除夕夜。
Kind of did the same thing here.
在这里也做了同样的事情。
We had them missing essentially, the Super Bowl, and that was the story.
我们基本上让他们错过了超级碗，这就是故事。
What do you got, Doug?
你有什么，道格？
And yes, it was CBS, Bears and the Colts.
是的，就是哥伦比亚广播公司、熊队和小马队。
Yeah, it was probably the biggest promotion.
是的，这可能是最大的促销活动。
We probably got a promo and a Super Bowl if we did a Super Bowl episode, and that was a big deal for us.
如果我们制作超级碗剧集，我们可能会得到宣传片和超级碗，这对我们来说是一件大事。
Did we get tickets?
我们买到票了吗？
It was the real question.
这是真正的问题。
I don't think we did.
我不认为我们做到了。
I don't think we did that.
我不认为我们这样做了。
Two and a half man got taken to you, exactly.
两个半人被带到了你身边，没错。
Well, that's a really clever way.
嗯，这真是一个聪明的方法。
I mean, it's funny to think about, like, how do you write a Super Bowl episode where you're not in Super Bowl?
我的意思是，想想很有趣，比如，如果你没有参加超级碗，你如何写一个超级碗剧集？
Well, you make it about death and a funeral and all the things that are keeping them from the Super Bowl.
好吧，你把它写成关于死亡和葬礼以及所有阻止他们参加超级碗的事情。
Actually seeing it, yeah.
其实亲眼所见，是啊。
I was really struck in this episode by the construction of it.
在这一集里，我对它的结构感到非常震惊。
So before the cold open, you get, you get the first half premise, which is like, we can't watch the Super Bowl because this guy we barely know died.
所以在冷开场之前，你得到了，你得到了上半场的前提，这就像，我们不能看超级碗，因为这个我们几乎不认识的人死了。
and we have to go to this funeral.
我们必须去参加这个葬礼。
So it's such like quick, swift storytelling.
所以这就像快速、迅速地讲故事一样。
And then the second bit is the Super Bowl happened and now we're gonna try to not learn who won, so we can all watch it together and preserve this tradition.
第二点是超级碗发生了，现在我们要尽量不知道谁赢了，这样我们就可以一起观看并保留这一传统。
I'd forgotten the detail where they get essentially kidnapped by a very drunk Carl the bartender.
我忘记了他们被喝得酩酊大醉的酒保卡尔绑架的细节。
That was a delicious one.
那是一顿美味的饭。
I'd forgotten it.
我已经忘记了。
That's what keeps them told 230 in the morning.
这就是让他们早上接到230号通知的原因。
Yeah.
是的。
That was for amusing to me.
那是为了让我觉得有趣。
Rob, what was it like directing this episode?
罗布，导演这一集感觉如何？
Let's get into it.
让我们开始吧。
Let's uh, because you got thrown into the wolves on that first episode where you were literally break You were there broke break glass in case of emergency rob comes out pam goes home sec Columns was the first real one that you weren't just like brought in and then by this one did this feel like okay?
让我们呃，因为你在第一集中被扔进了狼群，你真的崩溃了你在那儿打破了玻璃，以防紧急情况抢劫出来帕姆回家秒专栏是第一个真正的你不只是被带进来的，然后通过这个感觉还可以吗？
I've got my sea legs doing this now.
我现在已经开始做这件事了。
This was kind of your third one the first one has an asterisk I mean yeah, and I'm also on stage a lot prior to this anyway as a writer or as a and so it was all felt like home It was easy that way.
这是你的第三个，第一个有一个星号，我的意思是，是的，而且在此之前我也经常作为一名作家或作为一名作家登上舞台，所以一切都感觉像在家里一样，这样很容易。
I liked everybody.
我喜欢每个人。
I knew everybody.
我认识每个人。
It was you're just and it's all it is a well-oiled machine And you know if I stayed in my office, it probably would look pretty similar and I know that and so I Honor that and there's an incredible template and you kind of just do the template and You add your you can try to add a little here and there, but it is well written and it's pretty clear on the page These were your first big episodes of network TV you directed, right?
你只是，这就是一台运转良好的机器你知道，如果我留在我的办公室，它可能看起来非常相似，我知道这一点，所以我尊重这一点，有一个令人难以置信的模板，你只需做模板，你添加你的你可以尝试在这里和那里添加一点，但它写得很好，在页面上很清楚这些是你导演的网络电视的第一大集，对吗？
You were just starting the director.
你刚刚开始担任导演。
I directed a bunch of single cam, this was my first four camera.
我导演了一堆单机位摄影机，这是我的第一个四机位摄影机。
Okay, right, right, of course, you had done, you had even done your own, right?
好吧，对，对，当然，你已经做到了，你甚至已经做到了你自己的，对吧？
Was that a tough transition or not much at all, just because it's- They're a very different skill, I mean, the camera parts are different skill sets.
这是一个艰难的转变还是根本没有太大的转变，只是因为它们是一种非常不同的技能，我的意思是，相机部分是不同的技能组。
Right.
正确的。
The directing actors are similar, but the camera parts are, I actually find single camera easier.
导演是相似的，但相机部分是，我实际上觉得单机更容易。
And that 4K, it's a skill that you need to learn.
4K，这是一项你需要学习的技能。
And I think once you've learned it, it's easier.
我认为一旦你学会了它，事情就会变得更容易。
But it's like there's a learning curve on it.
但这就像有一个学习曲线。
Because there's a lot happening at once and you just got it nowhere to look.
因为同时发生了很多事情，而你却无处可寻。
Right.
正确的。
Rob, can you tell us like how you found your way into like writer's rooms?
罗布，你能告诉我们你是如何进入作家的房间的吗？
Like what was your, what's the cliffness version of like how you got to where you got?
就像你的经历一样，你是如何到达目的地的悬崖版本是什么？
I wrote, I went to, I mean, the whole history, the whole thing.
我写了，我去了，我的意思是，整个历史，整个事情。
I went to drama school.
我去了戏剧学校。
I went to drama school as a set designer.
我以布景设计师的身份进入戏剧学校。
And then I started directing.
然后我开始导演。
And I wanted to direct movies and I didn't have any idea how.
我想导演电影，但我不知道该怎么做。
So I started directing.
所以我开始导演。
I was directing a lot of my friends' plays and I was telling them, oh, I think you should rewrite it this way and they never would.
我导演了很多朋友的戏剧，我告诉他们，哦，我认为你应该这样重写，但他们永远不会。
So then I said, oh, I better start writing.
然后我说，哦，我最好开始写作。
And I started with sitcoms because they were shorter and more kind of bite-size.
我从情景喜剧开始，因为它们更短、更小。
And I wrote a couple of specs and I got onto a phrase you're pretty quickly and luckily and easily.
我写了几个规格，然后我得到了一个短语“你很快、很幸运、很容易”。
Just from spec scripts you had written.
仅来自您编写的规范脚本。
Yeah.
是的。
Wow.
哇。
That's a good first gig.
这是一个很好的第一场演出。
truth is I wrote a Seinfeld that I rewrote five time it took about a year to write and if I told anybody that nobody would have hired me and then I was working on the second one those days you needed two specs I was working on a Frasier actually and I was four months into that and I had the meeting I went with I went to the Diane English show with love and war and I went into the meeting and said we like this can you get it can you write if I give you two weeks can you write another respect script.
事实是，我写了一部宋飞传，我重写了五次，花了大约一年的时间，如果我告诉任何人没有人会雇用我，然后我正在写第二部，那些日子你需要两个规格，我实际上正在写一部《弗雷泽》，我已经四个月了，我参加了会议，我带着爱和战争去了黛安英语秀，我参加了会议，说我们喜欢这个，你能写吗，如果我给你两周时间，你能写另一个尊重剧本吗？
I did not tell her I was four months into another spec script.
我没有告诉她我已经四个月了才开始编写另一个规范脚本。
And I said, two weeks, that's hard.
我说，两周，这很难。
But I'll try.
但我会尝试。
And so I that's what I did.
所以我就是这么做的。
I heard you tell the story on the love and worry watch podcast.
我听到你在《爱与忧虑》播客上讲述了这个故事。
Rob, it's hard for me to think about you doing any other job.
罗布，我很难想象你还从事其他工作。
Like the way you were set, I was just like, like speaking of an accountant, like I couldn't see you going to an office job or doing it kind of respect like you just seem like a guy who should be showing up and thinking of funny things to put on screen like that's that's that I found that I found my call you know you really did you really did and you married or not a writer also so yes who also does funny things yeah we just walk around the house being fucking hilarious yeah all day long all day long yeah okay so then you directing this one I like this This one kind of also had a lot, it had a lot of bells and whistles and it had some visual stuff.
就像你的设定一样，我就像说起会计师，就像我看不到你去办公室工作或做这种尊重，就像你看起来像一个应该出现并思考有趣的事情放在屏幕上的人一样，那就是我发现我发现我的电话，你知道你真的做了你真的做了，你结婚了或者不是作家也所以是的，谁也做有趣的事情是的，我们只是在房子里走来走去，整天他妈的搞笑，是的，好吧，好吧那么你导演的这个我喜欢这个这个也有很多，它有很多花里胡哨的东西，它有一些视觉上的东西。
So that's what I liked the most.
所以这就是我最喜欢的。
So it was fun to do in that sense.
所以从这个意义上说，这样做很有趣。
I really liked the quad split speaking of like the skill of directing multi cam is having a big screen with four boxes in it.
我真的很喜欢四分割，就像导演多镜头的技巧是有一个大屏幕，里面有四个盒子。
And we kind of owned that and did that as a device on this was kind of like a nod to 24, I guess would do stuff like that, the show 24.
我们有点拥有它，并这样做，因为这个设备有点像向 24 点点头，我想会做类似的事情，节目 24。
That was a fun bell and whistle.
这是一个有趣的花哨的事情。
And there was a lot of like the point of view up from the casket.
从棺材上往上看，有很多类似的观点。
If you also from the Ted's mask, what's that called?
如果你也来自泰德的面具，那叫什么？
Since we've done better than 5,000.
因为我们已经做得比 5,000 更好了。
Yeah.
是的。
There was some fun stuff.
有一些有趣的事情。
You had a stunt, you had a flipping not Josh Radner, but kind of looked like Josh Radner.
你有一个特技，你有一个翻转，不是乔什·拉德纳，但看起来有点像乔什·拉德纳。
It looked like me.
它看起来像我。
I mean, Jordana said, how did you do that?
我的意思是，乔丹娜说，你是怎么做到的？
It looked really good.
看起来真的很好。
And I said, I don't believe I did that.
我说，我不相信我这么做了。
The thing about that that was fun, I learned the stunt guy came in, and he said, we worked it all out, and then the stunt guy does it, and there's no trick, it just hurts.
这件事很有趣，我得知特技演员进来了，他说，我们把一切都解决了，然后特技演员就这么做了，没有什么技巧，只是很痛。
That was the thing that was shocking.
这才是令人震惊的事情。
The guy just lands on his back and it hurts.
那家伙只是仰面着地，很疼。
And then it didn't get it right.
然后它就没有得到正确的结果。
He had to do it again.
他必须再做一次。
And everyone's like, oh, I'm like grumbling.
每个人都说，哦，我就像在抱怨。
And then we did it again.
然后我们又做了一次。
But then the stunt guys are always like, all right, cool.
但特技演员总是觉得，好吧，很酷。
Let's do this incredibly painful thing again.
让我们再做一次这件极其痛苦的事情吧。
This poor guy hurts.
这个可怜的家伙受伤了。
The old guy just says, yeah, you're doing this one.
老家伙只是说，是的，你正在做这个。
And he looks at me like, all right, I'll do it.
他看着我，好像在说，好吧，我会做的。
Not only did I notice that it was a stunt guy, but in the construction of the sensory depravator, I said to Jordana, those aren't my hands.
我不仅注意到那是一个特技演员，而且在构建感官破坏者时，我对乔丹娜说，那不是我的手。
We got a stunt guy for my hands.
我们找了一个替身演员来帮我。
That's really funny.
这真的很有趣。
What were you doing that day?
那天你在做什么？
We couldn't get your hands.
我们没能抓住你的手。
Yeah, no idea.
是的，不知道。
No, because the camera guy's right there.
不，因为摄像师就在那里。
It's probably the camera guy had a wee channel of his own hands.
可能是摄像师自己手上的通道太窄了。
But they also had, they had wisps of like, what looked like my hair kind of in the top of the frame.
但他们也有，他们有几缕类似的东西，看起来像我的头发，在框架的顶部。
That's really weird.
这真的很奇怪。
I don't remember that way at all.
我根本不记得是这样的。
That's really funny.
这真的很有趣。
Yeah, I'm certain they weren't my hands.
是的，我确信那不是我的手。
I can confirm that.
我可以证实这一点。
I know what they look like.
我知道他们长什么样。
Yeah, any other strong memories Rob from directing this episode?
是的，罗布在执导这一集时还有其他深刻的记忆吗？
I had a memory and this is this crazy.
我有一段记忆，这太疯狂了。
I thought, did we at one point with the football guy's name, Emmett Smith?
我想，我们是否曾经知道过那个橄榄球运动员的名字，埃米特·史密斯？
Did we tackle him?
我们对付他了吗？
Was there a bit where we tackled him?
我们有没有对付他的地方？
I could have sworn we tackled him.
我可以发誓我们已经解决了他。
That is 100% my memory of it.
这就是我100%的记忆。
I think we shot a promo for the episode with him.
我想我们和他一起拍摄了这一集的宣传片。
Oh, okay.
哦好的。
That's right.
这是正确的。
That's what it was.
就是这样。
So you did it, you're not listening.
所以你就这么做了，你不听。
I remember I got the direct tackling Emmett Smith.
我记得我直接拦截了埃米特·史密斯。
Was it all five of us tackling him, or was it just Neil?
是我们五个人一起对付他，还是只是尼尔一个人？
Something like that.
类似的事情。
Yeah, I think it was all of us.
是的，我想我们所有人都是如此。
And that was the promo that aired during Super Bowl.
这就是超级碗期间播出的宣传片。
Yeah, there you go.
是的，就这样。
I knew I remembered that.
我知道我记得那件事。
And remind me, I'm just now remembering this.
提醒我一下，我现在才想起这一点。
Did he say dance because he had just one dancing with the stars?
他说跳舞是因为他只和星星跳舞过一次吗？
Yes, there are a few things in here that you're like, what the fuck was that?
是的，这里有一些你喜欢的东西，那到底是什么？
Again, there's a little more topicality in this one than there are in some others.
再说一次，这个话题比其他一些话题更具话题性。
Like the reference to like the Janet Jackson thing.
就像提到喜欢珍妮·杰克逊的事情一样。
Well, that's funny.
嗯，这很有趣。
That's funny.
那很好笑。
That was funny.
这很有趣。
Do people still know that?
人们还知道吗？
Oh, I think that's, that's entered the cultural kind of Let's go.
哦，我想那就是，这已经进入了我们走吧的文化类型。
Old tech flag though, prayer over Tivo.
虽然是旧科技旗帜，但还是为 Tivo 祈祷吧。
Oh my God, the Tivo prayer.
天哪，蒂沃祈祷。
That made me sad a little bit.
这让我有点难过。
I was like, oh boy, Tivo.
我当时想，天哪，蒂沃。
Yeah.
是的。
It's great.
这很棒。
I love the bit.
我喜欢这一点。
It was a great thing.
这是一件很棒的事情。
You guys did it great.
你们做得很棒。
But it was like, oh, that's that's old tech.
但这就像，哦，那是旧技术。
That's what the office ladies say.
办公室里的女士们都是这么说的。
They say old tech alert, so we're stealing that from that.
他们说旧的技术警报，所以我们从中窃取了这一点。
Emmet Smith said that he was recognized way more for dancing with the stars than he was for being a Hall of Fame football player.
埃米特·史密斯表示，他因与明星共舞而获得的认可远多于他作为名人堂橄榄球运动员的认可度。
I was a little tidded.
我有点烦躁。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
And that was like a rival show that was like kicking our ass.
这就像一场竞争对手的表演，就像踢我们的屁股一样。
So it's probably panned us a little to reference them at all.
因此，我们可能对引用它们感到有些不满。
But anyway, but I forgot, it took me a second watching that.
但无论如何，但我忘记了，我花了一秒钟才看完。
I was like, oh, is that what that was?
我当时想，哦，是这样的吗？
He was dancing with stars 2019 years later.
2019年后，他与明星共舞。
That reference doesn't totally hold up, but here we are.
这个参考并不完全成立，但我们就在这里。
And then my only other strong memory was when Neil is handcuffed to the radiator.
然后我唯一的另一个强烈的记忆是尼尔被铐在散热器上的时候。
And he says, in my bookie, he worries.
他说，在我的赌注中，他很担心。
He worries, and I remember 100%, it was like more Jewish, now a little less Jewish, right there.
他担心，我百分百记得，那里更像是犹太人，现在又不那么犹太人了。
That was, and I use that direction all the time.
就是这样，我一直使用这个方向。
Do it to me, you get a style.
照我做，你就会有一种风格。
I always give more Jewish, less Jewish.
我总是给予更多的犹太人，更少的犹太人。
I use it shockingly, yeah.
我用它令人震惊，是的。
It's actually your only direction.
这实际上是你唯一的方向。
Exactly, and louder, quite.
完全正确，而且声音更大，相当。
I will say I always hit the sweet spot.
我会说我总是能达到最佳点。
Exactly, he did.
没错，他确实做到了。
He worries was really good.
他的担心真是太好了。
That was really funny.
那真的很有趣。
He worries.
他担心。
It's a very physical episode.
这是一个非常身体力行的情节。
There's a lot of running around and then seeing like stunts and that little kid extorting Marshall was really funny.
有很多跑来跑去然后看到像特技的东西，那个小孩子勒索马歇尔真的很有趣。
Yeah, I actually really, one thing I really liked about that little kid and sometimes with Lillie's classroom, like the little kid humor was like pretty uncentimetal.
是的，事实上，我真的很喜欢那个小孩的一件事，有时在莉莉的教室里，就像小孩的幽默感非常不合时宜。
Like this kid's quite evil.
看来这小子真是太邪恶了。
Oh yeah.
哦，是的。
Like he's not a good little saintly boy.
好像他不是一个善良的小圣人。
Yeah.
是的。
He's like a scheming little kid.
他就像一个诡计多端的小孩子。
Yeah.
是的。
And I think it's funny to be super uncentimetal about that stuff.
我认为对这些事情表现得超级不冷漠是很有趣的。
And yeah, that's a young Steven Miller.
是的，那是年轻的史蒂文·米勒。
Yeah, I think it was a young Steven Lloyd, it could also be a he was a good kid.
是的，我认为这是一个年轻的史蒂文·劳埃德，也可能是他是一个好孩子。
The kid that kid was good.
那个孩子那个孩子很好。
He was really funny.
他真的很有趣。
Rob, I feel like this was your joke is Rob, of course, is also a writer and would come in and pitch up the car and I wrote this episode.
罗布，我觉得这是你的笑话，罗布当然也是一名作家，他会进来并推销汽车，我写了这一集。
I don't think we wrote this joke.
我不认为这个笑话是我们写的。
The thing where the kid says, you know, $10 and Marshall Demiros and the kid goes, it just went up to eight.
那个孩子说，你知道，10 美元，然后马歇尔·德米罗斯和孩子走了，它就涨到了 8 美元。
It's one of my favorite.
这是我最喜欢的之一。
I love that.
我喜欢那个。
I love that I don't know if it's mine, but I did love it.
我喜欢它，我不知道它是不是我的，但我确实喜欢它。
It's such a good joke.
这是一个很好的笑话。
It's a joke joke.
这是一个笑话笑话。
I don't think we wrote I'm not being jealous, like I wish that was our joke.
我不认为我们写道我不是嫉妒，就像我希望这是我们的笑话一样。
You have to really, that's a joke you're like, if he's bad at math, well he's bad at teaching math.
你必须真的，这就是个笑话，如果他数学不好，那么他就不擅长教数学。
The joke is that he's not teaching math very well.
笑话是他数学教得不好。
That could fly by you, that joke, but it's so funny.
这个笑话可能会从你身边飞过，但它太有趣了。
Yeah, totally.
是的，完全可以。
And I think I remember with that kid that kid was great, but I basically told Jason, just direct him.
我想我记得那个孩子很棒，但我基本上告诉杰森，直接指导他。
Jason and him weren't sitting there, and I said, well, you're sitting alone and Jason basically directed him, he was great.
杰森和他没有坐在那里，我说，好吧，你一个人坐着，杰森基本上指导着他，他很棒。
Oh, that's funny.
哦，这很有趣。
That's always a good way with kids, I think that after if they connect, that they can do more than I do.
对于孩子们来说，这始终是一个好方法，我认为，如果他们建立联系后，他们可以做的比我更多。
It also means less work for you, so it was like pretty.
这也意味着你的工作量会减少，所以看起来很漂亮。
Exactly.
确切地。
Yeah.
是的。
You're just back there at the monitor, yelling more Jewish, or less Jewish, exactly.
你就在监视器后面，大声喊叫“更多犹太人，或者更少犹太人”。
So the kid, he's like, I don't know what you mean.
所以那个孩子，他就像，我不明白你的意思。
I don't know.
我不知道。
I hear.
我听到了。
I feel wrong.
我感觉不对。
And then I hear Jason whispering more Jewish.
然后我听到杰森低声说着更多犹太人的话。
To the kid.
给孩子。
It just went up, dang.
刚刚就涨了，哎呀。
I thought our oversized suits were really funny, and we looked like we were signing for the NBA draft.
我觉得我们的超大号西装真的很有趣，而且我们看起来就像是在参加 NBA 选秀。
That was, yeah.
那是，是的。
That was really funny.
那真的很有趣。
You know what struck me at the beginning of this episode?
你知道这一集一开始让我印象深刻的是什么吗？
All of a sudden our cast for just like one act of the show is Seinfeld.
突然之间，我们的演员阵容就像该剧的一幕一样，变成了《宋飞正传》。
They don't give a shit about this guy who died.
他们根本不在乎这个死去的人。
Right.
正确的。
They don't know who he was.
他们不知道他是谁。
Like this is a Seinfeld bit.
就像这是《宋飞正传》的片段。
It was funny because usually we're such an emo show.
这很有趣，因为我们通常都是一个情绪表演。
It's so heartfelt.
真是太有心了
But these guys had no idea who this guy who died was and they just want to not go to the funeral.
但这些人不知道死者是谁，他们只是不想参加葬礼。
I was like this feels almost not like our gang at the very beginning.
我一开始就觉得这几乎不像我们这帮人。
It was funny.
这很有趣。
Yeah.
是的。
But it was like a little darker than we said.
但它比我们说的要暗一点。
The coffin shot of them recognizing him and get remembering who he was is fantastic.
他们认出他并记住他是谁的棺材照片太棒了。
Really funny.
真的很有趣。
Well-directed Rob.
导演罗布.
Yeah, it's a real old-school bit.
是的，这确实是一个老派的东西。
My specialty.
我的专长。
Okay, so all of the various bells and whistles, was this the hardest one you had directed of the three?
好吧，那么所有的花里胡哨的东西，这是你执导的三部影片中最难的一部吗？
Because I feel like columns was a little more straightforward.
因为我觉得专栏更简单一些。
Scorpion the Told was a lot of talking at bars and stuff.
被告知的蝎子在酒吧之类的地方经常谈论。
This had a lot more.
这还有很多。
The bells and whistles are more fun for me than a big party scene where everyone's talking around.
对我来说，花哨的东西比每个人都在谈论的大型聚会场景更有趣。
I love all that, the bells and whistles.
我喜欢这一切，花哨的东西。
The more filming stuff is where I love the most.
更多的拍摄内容是我最喜欢的地方。
Yeah, yeah, I mean, it worked great.
是的，是的，我的意思是，效果很好。
I had not watched this episode in a really long time.
我已经很长时间没有看过这一集了。
I had forgotten things about it, even though we wrote it.
尽管我们写了它，但我已经忘记了它的事情。
Carter and I, it really moves, it really cooks this episode.
卡特和我，这一集真的很感人，也很精彩。
You really feel the ticking clock, You really feel like there's real stakes.
你真的感觉到时钟在滴答作响，你真的感觉有真正的赌注。
And it's funny, because then you remember it's just them watching a T-vode Super Bowl.
这很有趣，因为然后你就会记得只有他们在看 T-vode 超级碗比赛。
The stakes aren't that high, but it feels like very tense and suspenseful.
赌注不是那么高，但感觉非常紧张和悬念。
And I think you did a great job keeping that energy kind of like a live wire through the whole episode.
我认为你做得很好，在整个情节中都保持了像火线一样的能量。
You kept energy up.
你保持精力充沛。
Was that, what was that like?
那是、那是什么样子的？
Cause it's a three day shoot and you have to play it all like an action movie with a ticking clock, what was that?
因为这是一个为期三天的拍摄，你必须像一部动作电影一样播放它，那是什么？
I don't remember that, but I think it was on the page and it was in the editing.
我不记得了，但我认为它在页面上并且正在编辑中。
and the actors were great, but I think a lot of that was editing and Chris editing it, but yeah.
演员们很棒，但我认为其中很多都是剪辑，克里斯剪辑的，但是是的。
Good music, too.
音乐也不错。
It had good like 24 hour drama kind of music.
它有像 24 小时戏剧一样的音乐。
Well, it's also, it's a kind of comedic trope to take something just triflingly un-serious, or the stakes are so low and make it such high stakes.
嗯，这也是一种喜剧比喻，把一些不那么严肃的事情，或者赌注如此之低的事情，变成如此高的赌注。
Oh, that's my favorite trope, yeah, I love that.
哦，这是我最喜欢的比喻，是的，我喜欢这个。
But there is something underneath Ted's, you know, we talk a lot about like vertical family versus horizontal family, and this is like, I don't know if you'd heard this, Robert.
但在特德的背后，有一些东西，你知道，我们经常谈论垂直家庭与水平家庭，这就像，我不知道你是否听说过这个，罗伯特。
I heard that all TV is about family.
我听说所有的电视都是关于家庭的。
Like everything is about family on television.
就像电视上的一切都是关于家庭的一样。
Soprano is about, you know, cheers is about family, phrases is about family.
女高音是关于，你知道，干杯是关于家庭的，乐句是关于家庭的。
And this show is about people who choose family.
这个节目是关于选择家庭的人的。
They choose who their family is.
他们选择自己的家人。
So there's something in Ted's obsession with this tradition, even though he blacked out the first time he declared it was gonna be a tradition.
所以特德对这个传统的痴迷是有原因的，尽管他第一次宣布这将成为一个传统时就昏了过去。
But this idea that like, we have to do this together, it, I could make the argument that, at least from Ted's perspective, this is meaningful in a much deeper way, even though you can kind of shrug it off, it's just the Super Bowl.
但是这个想法，就像我们必须一起做这件事，我可以说，至少从特德的角度来看，这在更深层次上是有意义的，即使你可以耸耸肩，这只是超级碗。
Yeah, it is meaningful.
是的，很有意义。
And I thought the ending, I thought it was poignant at the end, I thought Bob, I really liked Bob Saggot at the end of this episode.
我认为结局，我认为最后是令人心酸的，我认为鲍勃，我真的很喜欢这一集结尾处的鲍勃·萨格特。
And really the narration, Bob was like just doing good narration acting at the end.
真正的旁白，鲍勃就像在最后做了很好的旁白表演。
And I liked his take on not remembering who won the game.
我喜欢他不记得谁赢了比赛的态度。
There's something so great about this episode that's all about who won the game.
这一集的精彩之处在于谁赢得了比赛。
And then Future Ted says, I don't remember.
然后未来特德说，我不记得了。
And we never say it, we never talk about it.
我们从不说出来，我们从不谈论它。
I will say that, Jordana, my wife, who, it's so funny, we recently gotten a number of letters and comments from people, including the opening letter today, because Jordana, if you've noticed, hasn't been doing her therapist observes, watches how I made your mother for the first time.
我要说的是，乔丹娜，我的妻子，这太有趣了，我们最近收到了很多人的来信和评论，包括今天的开场信，因为乔丹娜，如果你注意到的话，没有做她的治疗师观察，第一次观察我如何创造你的母亲。
And we revealed, and I think two episodes ago, that we had a baby a couple weeks ago.
我们透露，我想是两集前，我们几周前生了一个孩子。
So, so, Jordana has taken, um, leave maternity leave from her duties on this podcast.
所以，所以，乔丹娜已经从她在这个播客中的职责中休了产假。
But I will say, she probably would have, if she was doing one this week, she would have probably used this quote, which she leaned over to me at the end of the episode.
但我会说，如果她这周做的话，她可能会使用这句话，她在这一集结束时向我倾诉了这句话。
And she reminded me, there's a Whitman quote that is actually on a bench in Fort Green that we pass all the time, Fort Green Park.
她提醒我，惠特曼的一句话实际上就在我们经常经过的格林堡公园的长凳上。
And it's from Leaves of Grass.
这是《草叶集》里的。
And it simply says, we were together, I forget the rest.
它只是说，我们在一起，我忘记了其余的。
And to me, that's kind of what this episode is.
对我来说，这就是这一集的内容。
we were together, I forget the rest.
我们在一起，我忘记了其余的。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
That's great.
那太棒了。
The details don't matter.
细节并不重要。
It's about the camaraderie, even the attempt to have this shared experience together.
这是关于友情，甚至是尝试共同拥有这种经历。
That's what Ted's trying to create as a shared experience.
这就是特德试图创造的共享体验。
But I also loved, and we talk about this, Craig, like, so the thought experiment is they each have to not learn the score, the Super Bowl.
但我也喜欢，我们谈论这个，克雷格，喜欢，所以思想实验是他们每个人都必须不学习超级碗的比分。
What does that look like for Ted?
特德觉得这是什么样的？
What does that look like for Barney?
巴尼觉得这是什么样的？
What does that look like for Marshall?
马歇尔觉得这是什么样的？
What does that look like for Robin?
对于罗宾来说，这是什么样的？
So you have you have Robin and the you know on the local news like how does that play out with her?
所以你有罗宾和你在当地新闻中知道的人，比如她的结局如何？
Yeah, you know Lily in the classroom with Marshall.
是的，你在马歇尔的教室里认识莉莉。
How does that play out?
结果如何？
Like I imagine that's a really fun thing in a writer's room like to crack each version of that story It is I remember being very fun to crack that and I remember rewatching it now It was like Marshall's is the biggest reach so there's no reason Marshall had to be in Lily's classroom He is for show and tell, which I thought was really funny, which is, yeah, that was really funny.
就像我想象的那样，在作家的房间里破解这个故事的每个版本是一件非常有趣的事情我记得破解这个故事非常有趣，我记得现在重新观看它就像马歇尔的影响范围最大，所以马歇尔没有理由必须在莉莉的教室里他是为了表演和讲述，我认为这真的很有趣，是的，那真的很有趣。
And I do these going to hide out there because that's a safe space.
我这样做是为了躲在那里，因为那是一个安全的地方。
We're not going to be talking about the super like, guess that worked.
我们不会谈论超级之类的，猜猜这有效。
That one felt like a little bit of a reach because I was doing the same calculus.
这个感觉有点遥不可及，因为我也在做同样的微积分。
I was like, what did we do for everybody?
我当时想，我们为每个人做了什么？
I was a fun puzzle to crack, Marshall's like a little forced, but we knew he liked the bit of the kid extorting him.
我是一个有趣的谜题，马歇尔有点强迫，但我们知道他喜欢那个孩子勒索他的部分。
So we're like, all right, we're just going to pretend this makes any sense.
所以我们就像，好吧，我们只是假装这有道理。
And it puts him with Lily, you just wanted him, you just wanted him to spray apple juice on a kid's crotch.
这让他和莉莉在一起，你只是想要他，你只是想让他把苹果汁喷在孩子的胯部上。
And you worked backwards from there.
然后你从那里开始向后工作。
That's where the entire episode came from that moment.
这就是整个情节从那一刻开始的地方。
And then the network said it has to be a Super Bowl episode.
然后电视台说这必须是超级碗的一集。
So you excited?
那么你兴奋吗？
So like, all right, why wouldn't you be doing that to a kid?
那么，好吧，你为什么不对一个孩子这样做呢？
We were first engineered it.
我们首先设计了它。
That's really funny.
这真的很有趣。
Yeah, I that was the one that I was like, we reached for that one a little bit, but it was so funny.
是的，我就是这样的人，我们接触了一点，但这太有趣了。
It felt like sitcom logic that made sense to me.
这感觉就像情景喜剧的逻辑，对我来说很有意义。
Yeah, I kind of goes by like, all right, I'm in.
是的，我就好像，好吧，我加入了。
Yeah, I thought the the guy who played the it wasn't Sandy Rivers, but the guy who played the anchor with the copie did a great job He was funny.
是的，我以为扮演这个角色的人不是桑迪·里弗斯，但是那个扮演主播和副本的人做得很好，他很有趣。
He did a really good job.
他做得非常好。
I don't know.
我不知道。
I'm taking on Ducey Ducey as his name I know that guy.
我用杜西·杜西作为他的名字，我认识那个人。
Yeah, he was he was the I Used to know he's a good guy.
是的，他就是我以前知道他是个好人的人。
Funny.
有趣的。
He was great.
他很棒。
He was great that whole that whole newsroom sequence really worked Well, I thought it's so fun.
他很棒，整个新闻编辑室的序列真的很有效，我觉得这很有趣。
That was fun.
那很有趣。
I mean in directing wise it was fun to the guys The news guys had it like oh how to improvise with the camera.
我的意思是，在导演方面，这对那些新闻人员来说很有趣，就像哦如何用相机即兴创作。
I did like how the camera just was a character in the scene.
我确实喜欢相机只是场景中的一个角色。
They were trying to play ketchup, basically.
基本上，他们是想玩番茄酱。
Right.
正确的。
Because it wasn't going as planned, yeah.
因为事情没有按计划进行，是的。
The shitty pan over to the weather guy and it's a green screen and then it just kills him.
那个糟糕的镜头转向天气预报员，出现了一个绿屏，然后就杀了他。
The weather map fills in at a certain point behind him as he's eating the donut.
当他吃甜甜圈时，天气图在他身后的某个点被填满。
That was, you've got to direct the hell out of this one because all of those bits about the timing of how that camera's moving, the news camera, it really was well exchanged.
也就是说，你必须直接把这件事导演出去，因为所有关于摄像机移动时间的信息，新闻摄像机，真的都得到了很好的交换。
I also like the rewritten stuff for Robin when she's just generically talking about the winning team and the delicacy.
我也喜欢罗宾重写的内容，她只是笼统地谈论获胜的球队和美味佳肴。
That was great.
那很棒。
And this old man, he musted me, fell in love with you, New York City.
这位老人，他强迫我，爱上了你，纽约市。
And now, commercials.
现在，广告。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed Podcast.
大家好，我是 Alex Goldman，Hyper-Fixed 播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
like, I'm 30, and I'm scared to drive in New York.
就像，我 30 岁了，我害怕在纽约开车。
Or, why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者，为什么我倒车时无法调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car-related problems.
我们还解决与汽车无关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果您遇到问题，我们不仅会修复它，还会首先暴露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the Hyper-Fixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这是来自 Radiotopia 的 Hyper-Fixed 播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at HyperFixedPod.com.
无论您在哪里找到播客或在 HyperFixedPod.com 上都可以找到它。
End of commercials?
广告完结了？
Back to Shell.
回到壳牌。
One thing that we discovered, I think recently, probably before we even, after we booked you to come on, Rob, is this episode, and Doug, I'm going to throw it to a clip here.
我想最近我们发现的一件事，可能是在我们预订你上场之后，罗布，这一集，道格，我要把它放到这里的一个剪辑中。
This episode was selected when we, a variety did a piece when we hit 20 years, 20 years since the pilot, which was in September, variety did a piece where they did the top 20 episodes, the top 20 funniest or most beloved episodes, according to this one writer, Andrew McGowan, And he chose this one as his top, because it exhibited, I guess, the platonic ideal of what how much mother episode was to him.
这一集是在我们 20 周年的时候选择的，自试播集 20 年后，也就是 9 月份，综艺节目做了一个节目，他们做了前 20 集，前 20 名最有趣或最受欢迎的剧集，根据这位作家安德鲁·麦高恩的说法，他选择这一集作为他的最佳剧集，我猜，因为它展示了柏拉图式的理想，即母亲的剧集对他来说有多重要。
And that may or may not be my pen name, but yeah, we've never met Andrew again, exactly.
这可能是也可能不是我的笔名，但是，是的，我们再也没有见过安德鲁，确切地说。
And we have a clip.
我们有一个剪辑。
Here is Andrew McGowan.
请听安德鲁·麦高恩的报道。
Let's decide if it sounds like Rob doing a voice.
让我们判断一下这听起来是否像 Rob 的声音。
I don't think it will, but there's always that chance.
我认为不会，但机会总是有的。
We have a clip.
我们有一个剪辑。
heard we were doing this, and he wanted to weigh in and explain why he selected it as his top choice.
听说我们正在这样做，他想参与进来并解释为什么他选择它作为他的首选。
So let's listen to Variety writer, Andrew McGowan.
让我们来听听《综艺》杂志撰稿人安德鲁·麦高恩的看法。
Hi, Craig.
嗨，克雷格。
Hi, Josh.
嗨，乔什。
Hi, Alec, and hi, Rob.
嗨，亚历克，嗨，罗布。
A belated congratulations on 20 years since the premiere of How I Met Your Mother.
迟来的祝贺《老爸老妈的浪漫史》首映 20 周年。
For the milestone anniversary, I had the pleasure of revisiting the show and ranking the top 20 episodes for a variety.
为了纪念这一里程碑式的周年纪念日，我有幸重温了该剧，并对各种综艺节目的前 20 集进行了排名。
The criteria was not an exact science, but I broadly weighed each episode based on its writing, direction, premise, humor, heart and message.
标准并不是一门精确的科学，但我根据每一集的写作、方向、前提、幽默、内心和信息对每一集进行了广泛的权衡。
While there were many episodes that pained me not to include on the list, I think that I always knew that Monday Night Football would top it.
虽然有很多剧集让我很痛苦，但我想我一直都知道周一橄榄球之夜会名列前茅。
The episode, I believe, epitomizes how I met your mother at its best.
我相信，这一集集中体现了我如何遇见你母亲最好的一面。
It's sort of a timeless episode, one that a seasoned fan of the show and a newcomer can appreciate equally.
这是一部永恒的剧集，经验丰富的剧迷和新人都可以同样欣赏。
The premise is relatable, not just of friends watching the Super Bowl together, but of friends trying to share a common experience and keep a tradition alive against the odds.
这个前提是相关的，不仅是朋友们一起观看超级碗，而且是朋友们试图分享共同的经历并在困难中保持传统。
And in facing those odds, we get to see each of the characters showcase some of their most quintessential qualities across this one main A story that splinters in four different ways.
面对这些困难，我们看到每个角色在这个以四种不同方式分裂的主要故事中展示了他们最典型的品质。
Barney's emotional zanniness and unhinged mystery is shown through his gambling addiction, Robin's unglamorous life as a local newscaster is seen and how unprofessional she can get away with acting on air.
巴尼的赌博成瘾展现了他情感上的热情和精神错乱的神秘感，罗宾作为当地新闻播音员的平淡生活以及她在广播中的表演是多么不专业。
Marshall's conflict with the five-year-old in Lily's class shows his boyish endearing demeanor and Ted's innovation and excitement with the sensory depurator 5,000 brings out his geekiness.
马歇尔与莉莉班上五岁孩子的冲突显示了他孩子气的讨人喜欢的举止，而泰德对感官净化器 5,000 的创新和兴奋则凸显了他的极客气质。
But of course it's the end of the episode that I believe elevated above the rest, how they all fail to evade the score of the game, but still walk the game together and realize that it's the time spent together that brings value to the tradition.
当然，我认为这一集的结尾比其他部分更重要，他们都未能逃避游戏的得分，但仍然一起走完游戏，并意识到正是在一起度过的时间为传统带来了价值。
When Future Ted narrates that all these years later, he can't remember who won or who even played the game, but he remembers eating wings, laughing, hanging out with his friends.
多年后，当未来的泰德讲述这件事时，他不记得谁赢了，甚至不记得谁玩了这个游戏，但他记得吃鸡翅、大笑、和朋友们一起出去玩。
I think that really encapsulates the show's broader meaning, more so than the engine of Ted meeting the mother.
我认为这确实概括了该剧更广泛的意义，比泰德遇见母亲的引擎更重要。
How I met your mother, I believe, is about friendship.
我相信我是因为友谊才认识你母亲的。
It's about a time in one's young adulthood when friends serve as family and the most important memories are not necessarily defined by the headline events, but rather by who you share them with.
这是关于一个人年轻时的一段时光，那时朋友就像家人一样，最重要的记忆不一定是由头条新闻定义的，而是由你与谁分享的。
So that's why I ranked Monday Night Football at the top of the list.
这就是为什么我将《周一橄榄球之夜》排在了榜首。
Thank you all so much for creating this wonderful series that means so much to me and so much to so many.
非常感谢大家创作了这个精彩的系列，这对我和很多人来说意义重大。
Overall, there is so much to learn from appreciate and empathize with over the course of the nine seasons.
总的来说，在这九季的过程中，有很多值得学习、欣赏和同情的地方。
And it will always hold a special place in my heart.
它永远在我心中占有特殊的位置。
So thank you again and congratulations again.
再次感谢并祝贺。
Craig, I hope to catch up with you soon.
克雷格，我希望很快就能找到你。
And gosh, Alec Rob, I hope to cross paths with you in the future.
天啊，亚历克·罗布，我希望将来能与你相遇。
Thank you so much.
太感谢了。
That's great, Andrew.
太好了，安德鲁。
That was such a thoughtful and smart.
那真是一个深思熟虑和聪明的人。
And Rob, how do you feel about that?
罗布，你对此有何感想？
You helmed the episode.
你主持了这一集。
He said is the best one to him at of 200 days.
他说这是他200天以来最好的一次。
Well, I think it is what Josh said, it was like it's about the most mundane thing.
嗯，我想这就是乔什所说的，这就像是关于最平凡的事情。
So the other, the emotion came through.
所以另一方面，情感也随之而来。
If it was a more important event, it wouldn't have been as impactful.
如果这是一个更重要的事件，它的影响力就不会那么大。
Right, right.
对，对。
Yeah.
是的。
You know, I just this morning started listening to Ezra Klein just posted like an episode of his show from 2023.
你知道，我今天早上才开始听 Ezra Klein 刚刚发布的内容，就像他 2023 年节目的一集一样。
And it's with an author who wrote a book about hanging out.
和一位作家一起写了一本关于闲逛的书。
the pleasures of hanging out with, for no particular reason, and how we don't do it anymore.
没有什么特别的原因，一起出去玩的乐趣，以及我们如何不再这样做了。
And there's this real, you know, there's much written about the kind of loneliness epidemic and isolation and what the phones are doing to us, but they really interrogate, I've only listened to about 20 minutes of it, but they really interrogate this kind of lost world of hanging out, which this show is, if any show is a hanging out show, how we met mothers a hanging out show.
这是真实的，你知道，有很多关于孤独流行和孤立以及手机对我们做了什么的文章，但它们确实审问了，我只听了大约20分钟，但它们确实审问了这种失去的闲逛世界，这个节目就是，如果有节目是闲逛节目，我们如何遇见母亲就是闲逛节目。
And they're just, they're sitting around that booth, drinking beer, making each other laugh, for no reason other than the delight in each other's company.
他们只是坐在那个摊位周围，喝着啤酒，互相开怀大笑，没有任何原因，只是为了彼此的陪伴而感到高兴。
Yeah.
是的。
And I think in the same way that Gen Z loves hearing about like 90s childhoods, like 80s, 90s analog childhoods, because it starts to feel like this lost world that they never got to know because they all had digital childhoods.
我认为，就像 Z 世代喜欢听到 90 年代的童年一样，就像 80 年代、90 年代的模拟童年一样，因为这开始让人感觉这是一个他们从未了解过的失落的世界，因为他们都有数字童年。
And I think part of the, one of the things, Rob, that we're really interrogating on the show like the long tail of it, why people still watch it and care about it and other shows that were even more popular than we were on when we were on the air have kind of faded in the cultural memory.
我认为，罗布，我们真的在追问这个节目的一部分，就像它的长尾一样，为什么人们仍然观看它并关心它，而其他比我们播出时更受欢迎的节目已经在文化记忆中消失了。
But for some reason, this show still has a beating heart and a place in the cultural firmament.
但出于某种原因，这部剧仍然有一颗跳动的心，并在文化领域占有一席之地。
So, I think that's one of the reasons.
所以，我认为这是原因之一。
There's something pleasurable about watching people face to face care about each other, live life together, share experiences together, celebrate holidays and super bowls together.
看着人们面对面互相关心、一起生活、一起分享经历、一起庆祝节日和超级碗是一件令人愉快的事情。
There's something, it touches something in us that we all want, but might not currently have.
有一些东西，它触动了我们内心的一些东西，我们都想要，但目前可能还没有。
I think that's right.
我认为这是对的。
I think it scratches an itch.
我认为它会让人发痒。
I think there's something about seeing, even that they all decide this is important.
我认为观看是有一定意义的，即使他们都认为这很重要。
They all decide it's so important not to hear this result.
他们都认为不听到这个结果非常重要。
Yeah.
是的。
And there's a funny thing, like even though I said they were a bit callous about poor Mark who died, there's a funny kind of thematic overlap of like, well, that's how it ends for everybody.
还有一件有趣的事情，就像尽管我说他们对死去的可怜的马克有点冷酷无情，但有一种有趣的主题重叠，就像，好吧，这就是每个人的结局。
So eventually we all die at some point.
所以最终我们都会在某个时刻死去。
And this idea of what's so great about the ending or the results, right?
这个关于结局或结果的伟大想法是什么，对吗？
Who cares who won that game?
谁在乎谁赢了那场比赛？
Who cares what the end is?
谁在乎结局是什么？
The end is, you know, the ultimate end is we all die.
结局是，你知道，最终的结局是我们都死了。
Well, that's also, but we better enjoy watching the fucking game together as the most important part.
好吧，那也是，但我们最好享受一起观看他妈的比赛，这是最重要的部分。
The end result is not the most important thing.
最终的结果并不是最重要的。
Well Craig, that's what our kind of response is when people say like, this could have been 15 minutes.
克雷格，这就是当人们说“这可能需要 15 分钟”时我们的反应。
It's like, well, that's not an interesting show.
就好像，嗯，这不是一个有趣的节目。
You know, like the entire show was always about the journey.
你知道，就像整个节目总是关于旅程一样。
It was always about, and when people would get upset, you know, when the show was on the air, there were certain how I made your mother obsessives that were obsessed with who the mother was.
这总是关于，当人们感到不安时，你知道，当节目播出时，我如何让你的母亲着迷，他们着迷于母亲是谁。
Like that was the big mystery to crack as if this was like a true crime podcast or something.
就像这是一个需要破解的大谜团，就好像这就像一个真正的犯罪播客或其他东西一样。
But that was never the thing.
但事实并非如此。
I mean, it was a fun thing to hang it on.
我的意思是，把它挂起来是一件很有趣的事情。
and it probably helped you guys sell the show to have a kind of hook, but that was never the thing.
这可能有助于你们卖掉这部剧，因为它有一种吸引力，但事实并非如此。
The thing was always, how do we create a context where people can hang out and love each other and laugh?
问题始终是，我们如何创造一个人们可以闲逛、彼此相爱、欢笑的环境？
And I think maybe Andrew was hinting at that in his thoughtful answer too.
我想也许安德鲁在他深思熟虑的回答中也暗示了这一点。
Like there's something, this is in miniature the entire series in some way.
就像有什么东西一样，这在某种程度上是整个系列的缩影。
Yeah, there's gonna be a result, there's gonna be a score.
是的，会有一个结果，会有一个分数。
There will be a thing ascertained and the clock will stop and it'll be a result and they don't remember what the fucking result is.
将会有一件事被确定，时钟会停止，这将是一个结果，但他们不记得他妈的结果是什么。
The whole episode is about that and you never hear what it is.
整集都是关于这个的，但你永远不会听到它是什么。
And I think that's a really great way to say it's the journey that matters.
我认为这是一个很好的方式来表达旅程才是重要的。
And it's being together that matters.
在一起才是最重要的。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, it wasn't also there was a little bit of a wink to the series, because in the narrate at the very end, he says like, even though you know how it's gonna end, that's not the point.
好吧，这个系列也没有一点眨眼的地方，因为在最后的叙述中，他说，即使你知道它会如何结束，但这不是重点。
That's not the point.
这不是重点。
And he's telling his kids about their mother, they know how it is.
他正在向他的孩子们讲述他们的母亲，他们知道那是怎么回事。
So it's not about that.
所以不是这个问题。
Yeah, it's not about them.
是的，这与他们无关。
Yeah, and like we talk about the best how many mother episodes are kind of like, They're self-contained, you can watch them.
是的，就像我们谈论最好的《多少母亲》剧集一样，它们是独立的，你可以观看它们。
I think we know the best one, however, but go on.
不过，我认为我们知道最好的一个，但继续吧。
You're gonna be dining out on this for years.
你会在外面吃饭很多年。
But we can watch it as a self-contained story, but it also kind of winks at our gestures towards the larger story that it's a part of.
但我们可以把它当作一个独立的故事来看待，但它也对我们对它所属的更大故事的态度眨了眨眼。
The mini mystery, the mystery and miniature.
迷你之谜，神秘又微型。
How are they gonna, this has a little bit of that too.
他们会怎么样，这也有一点。
It's not quite exactly, exactly.
不完全准确。
And also, it was funny, I think it was Atlantic City you establish that Barney was like an insane gambler.
而且，很有趣，我认为是大西洋城你确定巴尼就像一个疯狂的赌徒。
And then you had to kind of go back and go, well, how did Barney become an insane gambler?
然后你必须回去想想，巴尼是怎么变成一个疯狂的赌徒的？
A $1 dollar bet with Marshall at the Super Bowl.
在超级碗比赛中与马歇尔打赌 1 美元。
God, that feels good.
天啊，这感觉真好。
It's so sad.
太悲伤了。
We see the beginning of a horrible addiction for Barney.
我们看到巴尼开始上瘾。
I know it's so great.
我知道这太棒了。
I also loved when Barney refuses to wear a suit to the funeral.
我也喜欢巴尼拒绝穿西装参加葬礼。
He shows up 100% almost mocking Ted with his style.
他的表现几乎百分百嘲讽泰德。
He's literally wearing a Ted Moseby outfit.
他确实穿着泰德·莫斯比 (Ted Moseby) 的服装。
He barely has the hoodie under a jacket.
他几乎没有在夹克下穿连帽衫。
Like it's very Ted.
就像是非常特德一样。
Yeah.
是的。
That's the one time you don't see it up.
那是你看不到它的唯一一次。
I like, I really like Neil's read on that he's worried about the suit on the dead body.
我喜欢，我真的很喜欢尼尔读到的，他担心尸体上的衣服。
The don't say it about it.
不要说这件事。
It's so, it must be so scared.
原来如此，一定很害怕吧。
The suit, the suit scared of the dead guy.
这套衣服，这套衣服害怕死人。
They're so heartless in that whole funeral scene.
他们在整个葬礼场景中是如此无情。
No, it sure is like for a show that was so heart forward and people really tending to each other.
不，这确实就像一部如此真诚、人们真正互相关心的节目。
and it really was like they weren't suddenly turned in the side fell cast.
确实就像他们没有突然转向侧面摔倒一样。
That's exactly what I didn't know the guy.
这正是我不认识的人。
I'm sorry, I don't know.
抱歉，我不知道。
I'll go the other side.
我去另一边。
They didn't know him.
他们不认识他。
Mr. I directed the best episode.
我先生导演了最好的一集。
I apologize for any even a hint of a criticism.
对于任何哪怕是一丝批评的暗示，我深表歉意。
And that by the way, that sounded like you.
顺便说一句，这听起来像你。
I think I was Andrew McGowan.
我想我是安德鲁·麦高恩。
I think that was you doing doing it with Rob.
我想那是你和罗伯一起做的。
What are your what other thoughts do we have?
您还有什么其他想法？
Do we have left?
我们已经离开了吗？
how do we, what have we not gotten to about your memories of directing?
关于您导演的记忆，我们还有什么没了解的？
I guess the best one.
我猜是最好的一个。
I know that when you head on your, what is it called?
我知道当你走向你的时候，它叫什么？
The, when you head on your contraption and you're in the bar?
当你打开你的装置并在酒吧里时？
Yeah.
是的。
I believe.
我相信。
Why am I the only one who remembers that?
为什么只有我一个人记得这件事？
He's on and he goes by the waitress and he sees the cleavage and goes on and then goes back for a second look.
他继续前进，经过女服务员，看到了乳沟，然后又回去看了第二眼。
That was a green version.
那是绿色版本。
100% of Craig Thomas on set.
100% 克雷格·托马斯在片场。
Oh my God, really?
天哪，真的吗？
Yes.
是的。
I was just throwing you on the bus, man.
我只是把你扔到公共汽车上，伙计。
You can't do that anymore, but 100% crinkles.
你不能再这样做了，但 100% 会起皱。
What if he goes back a second time?
如果他第二次回去怎么办？
Was that all right?
这样可以吗？
That's a great idea.
这是个好主意。
It's almost like a shot from airplane when the boobs just come in.
这几乎就像胸部刚进来时从飞机上拍摄的照片一样。
It's definitely an airplane.
这绝对是一架飞机。
And then just leave.
然后就离开吧。
It is so airplane.
真是飞机啊。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
I think I did add Josh crossing by on Neil when he's yelling on the sidewalk.
我想当尼尔在人行道上大喊大叫时，我确实添加了乔什从他身边经过的情况。
Oh, that made me laugh.
哦，这让我笑了。
I really liked that.
我真的很喜欢那个。
That made me laugh so hard.
这让我笑得很厉害。
I forgot about it.
我忘记了。
Very funny.
很搞笑。
that's when they can in the connection the connective P the transition pieces pushing on the TV in the bar and then we're in the newsroom on that shot like and the walk through the way those stories all connected that was also very well done as much as it pains me to compliment you Rob but you know what's funny Rob so like years later I so appreciate that shot so so Neil's on the ground screaming and then Ted walks by with the sensory defritter 3000 kind of feeling around New York City about to bump into a lamppost.
就在那时，他们可以在连接词P中将过渡片段推到酒吧的电视上，然后我们在新闻编辑室里拍摄那个镜头，并逐步了解这些故事的联系方式，这也做得很好，我很痛苦地赞美你，罗布，但你知道什么是有趣的罗布，所以就像几年后我非常欣赏那个镜头，所以尼尔在地上尖叫，然后特德带着感官除油器3000走过，有一种在新的感觉约克市即将撞上路灯柱。
You were very funny in that.
你那件事很有趣。
So I was probably not, you're right, I probably on Monday was not written in.
所以我可能没有，你是对的，我可能周一没有写进去。
By Wednesday, that's written in.
到周三，这件事就写好了。
But what people don't understand is moving the whole crew down to New York Street was a real process.
但人们不明白的是，将整个团队搬到纽约街是一个真实的过程。
You had a whole, you know, you're shooting down there, it's off the stage.
你有一个整体，你知道，你在那里拍摄，它在舞台外。
I had to come in and get, go through, you know, but, you know, I probably wasn't scheduled to work that day, but then I had to come in just to walk through in the background, which was the right narrative move and you laugh about it years later, but there's probably a part of you as an actor, you're like, I gotta come in on Thursday, I feel like I thought I was gonna go.
我必须进来，经历，你知道，但是，你知道，那天我可能没有安排工作，但后来我不得不进来只是为了在后台走一走，这是正确的叙事动作，几年后你会嘲笑它，但你作为演员的一部分，你会想，我必须在周四进来，我觉得我以为我会去。
This is why you, I don't think you were so quiet about it.
这就是为什么你，我认为你对此并不那么安静。
That is your strongest memories by protesting.
那是你抗议时最强烈的记忆。
He said, I'm not, if I'm doing this, I'm gonna do it in the fucking hands.
他说，我不会，如果我要这么做，我会在他妈的手里做。
That's really funny.
这真的很有趣。
I just heard that guy, that's funny.
我刚听说那个人，很有趣。
And the other side of it, He had to direct the camera guy because he did a lot of work and he had a look over it like you know If it's too jerky or two, so that was you're gonna.
另一方面，他必须指导摄像师，因为他做了很多工作，他仔细检查了一下，就像你知道的那样，如果它太生涩或两次，那就是你要的。
Let me shoot it Then you could have been your hands your hands.
让我开枪然后你就可以成为你的手了。
Yeah.
是的。
Well the century depravator stuff POV stuff That's that was very cool.
嗯，世纪堕落者的东西 POV 的东西 那真是太酷了。
We're that come from Craig.
我们来自克雷格。
Where'd that come from the room?
这是从房间里哪里来的？
Do you remember?
你是否记得？
It might have been it might have been me I don't know it might have that might have been like we wanted Ted's approach to be endearing Lee over thought dorky and somewhat but inventively architecty.
可能是我，我不知道，也可能是我们希望特德的方法让李讨人喜欢，而不是认为愚蠢和有点但富有创造性的建筑。
Did Cap and Crunch give us any money?
Cap 和 Crunch 给我们钱了吗？
Was that sponsored content or no?
那是赞助内容吗？
Sadly no, we missed a bet there.
遗憾的是没有，我们错过了那里的一个赌注。
But they could sponsor the podcast we're plugging in here on the podcast.
但他们可以赞助我们在播客上插入的播客。
They're still there, literally.
从字面上看，它们仍然在那里。
We don't have to call it a day, yeah.
我们不必到此为止，是的。
But that stuff must have been fun to shoot with the cameraman.
但和摄影师一起拍摄这些东西一定很有趣。
There was a lot of camera acting in this episode, right?
这一集中有很多镜头表演，对吧？
There was a lot of the camera was the joke for a lot of stuff in this episode.
在这一集里，有很多镜头是很多东西的笑话。
It was a fun one to do.
这是一件很有趣的事情。
You got to have fun.
你一定要玩得开心。
We handed you gold, Rob.
我们给了你金牌，罗布。
You handed you gold.
你给了你金子。
Oh, just get out of the way.
哦，别挡道。
Don't screw it up.
别搞砸了。
Yeah.
是的。
You know what else I liked is Ted missing the bartender's fist at the lab when he goes back to the sauce?
你知道我还喜欢什么吗？当泰德回到实验室时，他错过了实验室调酒师的拳头？
He has a proper depth present.
他有适当的深度。
He doesn't fully see the fist.
他没有完全看到拳头。
Yeah.
是的。
I mean, sometimes, you know, we've talked, Rob, like sometimes I had to be the kind of virtuous center of the show or the romantic hero.
我的意思是，有时，你知道，我们聊过，罗布，就像有时我必须成为节目中那种善良的中心或浪漫的英雄。
But there was something fun those episodes where I just get to be as big an idiot as everyone else.
但有一些有趣的情节，我变得和其他人一样大白痴。
Yeah.
是的。
And this is definitely like Ted's as big an idiot as everyone else in this episode.
这绝对就像特德和本集中的其他人一样是个大白痴。
He might be the biggest, yeah.
他可能是最大的，是的。
The idiocy was his idea.
这是他的愚蠢想法。
He is the absolute showrunner of idiocy on this one.
他绝对是这部影片的白痴制作人。
Right.
正确的。
Which I love.
我喜欢哪个。
I love that speed for Ted.
我喜欢特德的速度。
I think it was very important to sometimes see that side of Ted because it earns you the more earnest sincere parts later.
我认为有时看到特德的这一面非常重要，因为它会让你在以后获得更真诚的部分。
You need to know he's obsessed and he's gonna make the sensory decor 5,000 to care about him when he's gonna give a romantic speech.
你需要知道他很着迷，当他要发表浪漫演讲时，他会让感官装饰达到 5,000 来关心他。
and that he can he can hang with the gang in their in their weirdness like he's not and they listen to him yeah and you think he would wear it only when he got got to the bar and went inside but no he wears it on a street he also wears it up the staircase of his own apartment of the building and he was a barman wearing it in the apartment as a guy that's a little bit of a buy-to but it was funny it was a good Barney reveal Barney sneaking out um well it was a great one Rob You nailed it.
他可以，他可以和这帮人一起以他们的怪异方式相处，就像他不是一样，他们听他的，是的，你认为他只有在到达酒吧并进去时才会戴它，但不，他在街上戴它，他也在自己公寓的楼梯上戴它，他是一个酒吧服务员，在公寓里穿着它，作为一个有点买账的人，但有趣的是，这是一个很好的巴尼透露，巴尼偷偷溜出去，嗯，这是一个伟大的罗布，你成功了。
We'll give it to you.
我们会把它给你。
All I did was get handed great actors and a great script.
我所做的只是得到了出色的演员和出色的剧本。
So there you go.
所以就这样吧。
Well directed.
指导得好。
Well done, my friend.
干得好，我的朋友。
It was the perfect amount of Jewish this episode.
这是这一集犹太人的完美表现。
I just had a season one Rob Greenberg memory come rushing back to me that I would like to share until we got into when did we get into like the dressing rooms in the building behind the stage that was like season three.
我刚刚想起了第一季罗布·格林伯格的记忆，我想分享一下，直到我们什么时候进入像第三季那样的舞台后面的更衣室。
I think so.
我想是的。
Yeah.
是的。
So for the first two seasons, we had these trailers out in front of the and I emerged from my trailer and I think the first two seasons I had a bit of a not quite a scowl on my face but I was overly kind of thoughtful and I couldn't I couldn't lighten up my face but I remember leaving my trailer one day and I walked out and I see Rob across the way and he said smile your life is going so much better than you ever thought it would.
所以在前两季中，我们把这些预告片放在前面，我从预告片中走出来，我想前两季我的脸上有点不那么皱眉，但我太体贴了，我不能让我的脸变亮，但我记得有一天我离开我的预告片，我走出去，我看到对面的罗布，他微笑着说你的生活比你想象的要好得多。
That's an amazing thing to just have prepared to say around in the moment.
此刻就准备好说出来，真是一件了不起的事情。
It was true.
这是真的。
It was longer than two weeks, but thank you, Rob.
虽然时间已经超过两周了，但是谢谢你，罗布。
I did need someone to lighten me up and you were always you were always there for that.
我确实需要有人让我轻松起来，而你总是在那里。
So you were you were always good at that for all of us including me and Carter when we were the youngins, not knowing what we're doing.
所以你总是很擅长为我们所有人，包括我和卡特，当我们还是年轻人的时候，不知道我们在做什么。
Well, I think there was, what I was trying to say earlier was, you always reminded me that this was a great gig, like, like there's so many other harder ways to make a living than what we were doing.
嗯，我想，我之前想说的是，你总是提醒我，这是一场很棒的演出，就像，还有很多其他比我们所做的更困难的谋生方式。
And you were like a walking reminder of that.
你就像一个活生生的提醒者。
So thank you.
所以谢谢你。
You're welcome.
不客气。
And we knew we did, we knew we had a good one when we would pitch a bit in the room and Rob would say, yes, that's the green birdie and yes, give us one, Rob, we've, we've, we have to earn it.
我们知道我们做到了，当我们在房间里投球时，罗布会说，是的，那是绿色小鸟，是的，给我们一个，罗布，我们已经，我们已经，我们必须赢得它。
at the urn.
在瓮处。
You directed the best episode.
你导演了最好的一集。
I'm not a wind up monkey.
我不是一只发脾气的猴子。
You directed the best episode of How I Met Your Mother.
你执导了《老爸老妈浪漫史》中最好的一集。
That is what I hear.
这就是我所听到的。
Oh, come on.
哦，来吧。
You're really not going to give it up.
你真的不会放弃它。
Yes, all right.
是的，好吧。
Okay.
好的。
Well, we like to end most of these episodes with a written letter.
好吧，我们希望以一封书面信来结束大部分的情节。
We open often with a recorded letter.
我们经常以录音信开头。
But today we're ending with It's a beautiful, wonderful letter that we received.
但今天我们以我们收到的一封美丽而精彩的信结束。
If you would like to write us or leave us a voice note, possibly, hopefully to be read on the show, please go to howwemadeyourmother.com, H-W-M-Y-M.com.
如果您想给我们写信或给我们留言（希望能在节目中阅读），请访问 howwemadeyourmother.com、H-W-M-Y-M.com。
And wedding proposals are now accepted.
求婚现已被接受。
Wedding proposals are now accepted, is where most people are going to propose marriage these days.
求婚现已被接受，这是当今大多数人求婚的地方。
And go to contact and follow the instructions.
并前往联系并按照说明进行操作。
It should be pretty clear.
应该很清楚了。
But we love hearing from people what the show meant to you and any other things you want to share with us about the show and how it's affected your life.
但我们很高兴听到人们说这个节目对您意味着什么，以及您想与我们分享的有关该节目以及它如何影响您的生活的任何其他信息。
Anyway, here is a letter this is from Alex.
不管怎样，这是亚历克斯写来的一封信。
Dear Josh Craig and Alec, I hope this message finds you well.
亲爱的乔什·克雷格和亚历克，我希望这封信对您来说一切顺利。
My name is Alex, writing from far away the Balkan Peninsula in Serbia.
我叫亚历克斯，来自遥远的塞尔维亚巴尔干半岛。
Here most people I know watched him in high school back when seasons four and five were airing.
我认识的大多数人在高中时都看过他，当时第四季和第五季正在播出。
I somehow missed that wave.
我不知何故错过了那波浪潮。
I didn't begin watching the show until I was at university around 2013 to 2014, but the moment I did, I was completely hooked.
我直到2013年到2014年上大学时才开始看这个节目，但当我看的那一刻，我就完全被迷住了。
Since then, for the past 12 years, the show has been a quiet companion in my life.
从那时起，在过去的12年里，这部剧一直是我生活中安静的伴侣。
I've re-watched it many times, especially in the early days of COVID when I was 27, the same age as the characters in those early seasons.
我已经重看了很多遍了，尤其是在新冠疫情初期，当时我 27 岁，和前几季中的角色同龄。
Now, in my early 30s, re-watching the show again feels different yet equally powerful.
现在，我三十岁出头，再次观看这部剧，感觉不同，但同样震撼。
When I was younger, it was the love story that struck me.
当我年轻的时候，让我印象深刻的是爱情故事。
And now it's the whole worldview of the show, the friendships, the searching, the heartbreak, the growing up, the strange mix of melancholy and joy that adulthood brings.
现在是这部剧的整个世界观，友谊，寻找，心碎，成长，成年带来的忧郁和欢乐的奇怪混合。
There's an honesty in it that only grows with age.
其中有一种随着年龄的增长而增长的诚实。
And now with some distance, I also realize how much I miss the world the show portrays.
现在，随着距离的推移，我也意识到我是多么怀念这部剧所描绘的世界。
A few days ago, I re-watched the episode where the gang gets smartphones for the first time, and from today's perspective, it already feels like a classic, a little time capsule in a world that is slipping away.
前几天，我重看了这帮人第一次拿到智能手机的那一集，从今天的角度来看，它已经感觉像是一个经典，一个正在消失的世界中的小时间胶囊。
Originally I discovered Josh's music, unfortunately only last year, it's never too late.
最初我发现了 Josh 的音乐，不幸的是直到去年才发现，现在还不算太晚。
As someone who has been making music for a large part of my life, that immediately struck a chord in me.
作为一个一生大部分时间都在创作音乐的人，这立即引起了我的共鸣。
For the first time, I thought maybe I should also try to sing.
我第一次觉得也许我也应该尝试唱歌。
And so as a small homage to the show, I wrote two songs inspired by himium, something completely and utterly different from the music that I usually write and record.
因此，作为对这部剧的小小的致敬，我写了两首受 hiium 启发的歌曲，这与我通常写和录制的音乐完全不同。
Thank you for creating something so heartfelt, funny, human, and enduring.
感谢您创造了如此真诚、有趣、人性化和持久的东西。
has influenced more of my life than I ever expected a television show could.
对我生活的影响比我想象的电视节目还要大。
I would have a million in one questions, but I will let you guys answer each and every one of them weekly in your amazing podcast.
我会提出一百万个问题，但我会让你们每周在你们精彩的播客中回答每一个问题。
Wow.
哇。
Thank you so much, Alex.
非常感谢你，亚历克斯。
What a great letter.
多么好的一封信啊。
That was lovely.
那真是太可爱了。
That was lovely and kind of linked up with what we were talking about, about the lost world of actually spending time with each other and we're on screens, which ironically we are doing right now, spending time with each other on screen to talk about.
这很可爱，并且与我们正在谈论的内容有关，关于我们在屏幕上实际共度时光的失落世界，具有讽刺意味的是，我们现在正在这样做，在屏幕上共度时光谈论。
Thank you, Alex.
谢谢你，亚历克斯。
I'm so glad people in Serbia love the show.
我很高兴塞尔维亚人喜欢这个节目。
It's thrilling to hear the geographic reach of the show.
听到这个节目的地理影响力令人兴奋。
And Rob Greenberg, we're delighted to see you and to be able to chat with you about this episode.
罗布·格林伯格，我们很高兴见到您并能够与您讨论这一集。
And please let me know when you're in New York.
当你在纽约时请告诉我。
I will let you know it's a pleasure.
我会让你知道这是一种荣幸。
It's lovely to see your faces.
很高兴看到你们的脸。
We'll have you back.
我们会让你回来的。
Thank you for having me.
谢谢你有我。
It's hard for me to think of how I met your mother without you as a huge part of it.
我很难想象在没有你的情况下我是如何认识你母亲的。
And I'm so glad you were there that first day where I met everyone that changed my life.
我很高兴第一天你就在那里，我遇到了改变我生活的每个人。
And yeah, come back to me.
是的，回到我身边。
The earliest believer in it in so many ways, Rob.
罗布是在很多方面最早相信这一点的人。
You really were still there for me and Carter when we were in over our heads.
当我们陷入困境时，你确实还在我和卡特身边。
And I don't think the show would have been the same without you helping preserve it, what was special about it to begin with.
我认为如果没有你的帮助，这个节目不会是一样的，它首先有什么特别之处。
So thank you, we love you.
所以谢谢你，我们爱你。
Ladies and gentlemen, Rob Greenberg.
女士们先生们，罗布·格林伯格。
Thank you and I love you both.
谢谢你们，我爱你们俩。
So Alex, who wrote us this wonderful letter that we just read, he sent us in one of those two songs that he wrote that was inspired by how I met your mother and we're going to send you off with this one.
亚历克斯给我们写了这封精彩的信，我们刚刚读到，他给我们寄来了他写的两首歌中的一首，这首歌的灵感来自于我如何遇见你母亲，我们将用这首歌送你离开。
So here is that wonderful song.
这就是那首美妙的歌曲。
Thanks Alex for sending it in.
感谢亚历克斯寄来。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas and is presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳 (Josh Radner) 和克雷格·托马斯 (Craig Thomas) 主持并监制，并由 Office Ladies Network 和 Odyssey 出品和发行。
This episode is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
本集还由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛担任执行制作。
The show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matata.
该节目由我 Alec Lev 制作和编辑，我们的联合制作人是 Doug Matata。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves。
Our digital content producer, aka Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumberg.
我们的数字内容制作人，又名 Z 世代大师，是 Emily Blumberg。
Artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help the show.
对节目确实有帮助。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《New York City》，其他音乐由 Craig Thomas 和 Andrew Majuski 创作。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢洛拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Visit HowWeMajormother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
请访问 HowWeMajormother.com 了解更多信息，然后单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's newsletters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at JoshRadner.com.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Radner 的时事通讯，并在 JoshRadner.com 上查看他的音乐和其他所有内容。
After Craig Thomas' debut novel, that's not how it happened, wherever books are sold, and check out his other published writings at CraigThomasWriter.com.
在克雷格·托马斯的处女作之后，无论在哪里出售书籍，情况都不是这样的，请在 CraigThomasWriter.com 上查看他出版的其他作品。
And you can subscribe to my own Dead Fathers Society, also on Substack.
你也可以在 Substack 上订阅我自己的 Dead Fathers Society。
To learn more about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign, to raise money for congenital pediatric heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解有关如何做出改变的更多信息，这显示了正在进行的为先天性儿科心脏病研究筹集资金的活动，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”选项卡。
will, in fact, dance.
事实上，会跳舞。